When you're ready to create content for your first web video,...
...a great place to start is with a 30-second pitch.
A 30-second pitch summarizes your product or service...
...in the amount of time it takes to travel seven floors in an elevator.
It explains who you are, what you do, and how you are different.
Okay, imagine riding in an elevator with your perfect potential client.
What could you say in a few sentences that clearly explains your business in a nutshell?
You might answer these questions.
"What do you do and who do you serve,..."
"...or who is your target market?"
"What problem does your business solve?"
"How are you remarkable?"
In other words, "What makes you different and why should your potential customer care?"
Now, organize that information into a few exciting sentences.
Remember to keep it short, keep it simple, and keep it spicy.